uh welcome everyone I will um introduce
some of the topics that we think have a
lot of promise and potential
for those who are interested to join
this hackathon so before we jump into
that I wanted to remind everyone that
this is kind of an orientation or an
introduction to what's actually coming
and a little preview of expert talks
that we have scheduled all of this
information about the hackathon who will
be speaking when they will be speaking
what are they going to be speaking about
is available on the page for the
microbiome in health and wellness
hackathon so if trigori or someone could
share that link in the chat that would
be great
and
um after I complete this part of the
presentation also I hope that someone
will be able to give an overview of uh
the schedule and kind of how to register
and things like that
so as we go we mentioned
um the
hackathon for us is a little bit
different than what you would typically
think of a hackathon right typically
when people hear the word hackathon they
think competition somebody wins somebody
loses uh you know whoever wins gets it
all right
but what we are trying to do is make
this hackathon into a learning
experience and
um I hope that after today's
presentation will be a lot more clear
um how and why uh maybe you might be
interested in the microbiome as a
technology that
um you know really brings together these
very different kinds of skill sets uh
computer science is the focus of today's
session but we have previously talked I
think uh briefly about the microbiome as
a field within biotechnology and
business as a an important concept to
consider when you think about the
innovation
in the microbiome space and this is
aligned well with our approach in
general which is to provide Solutions
services and training in the field of
big data analytics and as a result of
this activity we have the platform that
you just signed up on and also I will
demonstrate a little bit of the platform
that you will have if you are less
familiar with bioinformatics how you can
nevertheless participate and do analysis
and kind of see what the data actually
tells us
so as a part of uh doing this work we
also interact with a network of experts
from around the world
um including Israel the US Sweden India
and many other countries and our goal is
always to bring together experts in the
field that can help us understand the
trends and Direction where that that
particular field is going and so
together with the experts for this
hackathon
we are also going to be learning
together with all of you about these
Trends about the need in the industry
about the progress that the researchers
are making and about the way that data
could be used to make that progress
accelerate that progress and and make it
more uh reliable
um in terms of that is really what we
see in the data and not just you know
hype that a lot of times unfortunately
um happens in this field as well
so why microbiome uh the reason we chose
to select this topic for this hackathon
and in general as a topic that we feel
is important is because
um it is a recently
um kind of
uh recently uh accelerating field where
a lot of investment has yielded
um insights that are very interesting
but
um unfortunately a lot of those insights
still remain to be proven in terms of
the value that they produce even though
a lot of larger companies and Industry
have adopted that this actually does
have a lot of potential and we have to
harness this potential now where has
this potential primarily been so far
primarily there's a focus on human
microbiome Therapeutics and kind of
thinking about the microbiome with
probiotics prebiotics so primarily the
gut microbiome now as you will hopefully
discover
um in this whole training period before
the hackathon and during the hackathon
itself
microbiome is a technology or a
microbiome as a field and and
metagenomics as a technology has the
potential to disrupt several different
domains and in
unexpected ways oftentimes So I myself
don't come from a microbiology
background but just preparing for this
hackathon I've learned so much about the
potential of the microbiome in in
clothing in skin treatment in Aging in
balding in so many different things so I
think it's a real exciting field and
unfortunately only when something
touches so many different things
it also becomes kind of questionable as
to how those specific ideas can be
translated into actual products and here
we can see a chart that in 2018
there have been over 1500 patent
applications and I think that trend is
continuing to grow unfortunately this
chart goes only to 2019 but in 2021 I
believe that this trend is continuing to
grow so there's really a lot of
innovative ideas that could be patented
that could result in tremendous business
as well as science breakthroughs so
um what are the specific challenges in
microbiome
and that we can contribute to that we as
a community we as a company you as
researchers students uh faculty other
companies maybe
um entrepreneurs what can we contribute
uh without necessarily having access to
lab space and to
um you know maybe microbiologists that
can modify strains of different bacteria
or you know design new Therapeutics and
and maybe phages that address specific
uh you know types of microbes so I think
the real benefit of microbiome as a
field is that there's a lot of data sets
that are publicly available and during
the hackathon
we will introduce you to a lot of these
uh data sets that we have been curating
as a team to highlight some of the
opportunities that we think are very
promising and then allowing our experts
to speak about the other components when
you look at these data sets what should
you consider what how can you frame your
questions in such a way that they become
interesting compelling Innovative and
addressing real challenges out there so
this availability of data I think is
really a trend that defines this field
because even surprisingly even to me
biotechnology startups rely on public
domain data sets to inform their initial
ideas and then essentially the the
company would validate a lot of those
insights that come out of the analysis
of publicly available data sets and the
same way with researchers right they
might have ideas that they also want to
validate first of on public domain data
set so there's a lot of reliance
on these data sets and the reason is
because they are done by professional
teams and professional Labs experts that
design these experiments and
Publications that then describe the
results as well right so
it's really interesting that any one of
us has access to those data sets now
unfortunately data sets are not easy to
work with and that's where engineering
computer science data science really can
play a major difference because the goal
of these disciplines is to really
translate this raw data to insights and
in addition to just insights those
insights need to be interpretable so
someone needs to understand the
mechanism of action and the biological
kind of context of what is being
described in this data they need to be
easily searchable
and they need to be visually compelling
and so I think those are the things that
we will focus on as we think about how
to make this kind of data-driven
innovation more applicable and useful
for actual users
and that's going to be more of the focus
of you know what I will speak in a few
more slides
now um why the hackathon as a learning
experience makes sense why this format
makes sense you know a lot of times when
we think about learning something new
There's no practical outcome and the
reason why there's no practical outcome
is because you know you're trying to
earn a certificate or maybe say I have
completed you know some course and now I
have some skills but who knows if those
skills are real most of the time and I
think you know I've done that myself as
well we go on some online learning
platform and we watch some video we read
some text and then we get a certificate
I mean how is that necessarily learning
I don't think that there is a lot of
practical outcomes from Simply doing
that what does make that much more
practical and I think more valuable is
when you come out with a real project
and you know that could be a research
project but in this case you can really
come out with a practical solution
um and that solution really shows that
you know you have skills you know how to
apply those skills and you have done the
research from the technology to The
Domain that you're in to actual business
value that you are producing so that's
the goal of this hackathon it's a
learning experience because it will
allow you to show your creativity
um your ability to overcome challenges
and solve problems
but also most importantly I think it's a
way to connect with others that can
contribute to your ideas refine them and
you know there's a a saying called iron
sharpens iron and I think in this case
uh we hope to bring together teams that
have the business
um Acumen and backgrounds that have the
data science skills and intuition and
also people that have the biotechnology
and the biology and the kind of Health
and Wellness thinking so that these are
real proposals of solutions that are
needed
okay
now how do we take these three points
innovate solve and connect and you know
start talking about the specific
challenges and opportunities with
microbiome so um I think that there's a
lot of funding that continues to be
poured into the microbiome space now as
I mentioned already
a lot of that funding goes towards
Therapeutics and things like Pro and
prebiotics and things like that so
what we are going to focus on and you
know that kind of funding um is a large
in amounts but you can see that the
number of uh these um Investments it
remains to be pretty low and that's
because it's a lot of money for only a
few products
um now if you are familiar with you know
even the stock market or or the economy
in general we know that actually small
and medium-sized businesses are the ones
that are most active and most Innovative
and they're able to you know a lot of
them fail but they are able to produce
real value and Innovation and so I think
what we are going to focus on is
pre-clinical health and wellness type
applications because we think that
there's a lot of opportunities to kind
of take those high level science and
make it practical in in the sense that
it is Data driven and proven but
nevertheless addresses the more
commonplace issues that we faced so in
just a few examples
uh silver has been known uh to resist to
have antimicrobial properties so there's
actually a lot of metals and different
types of
um you know materials that have
antimicrobial properties now this sounds
like a great idea to innovate and
understand how can antimicrobial type
material you know maybe suppress odor or
have some other good properties but we
need to remember that our skin also has
a microbiome right and and that
microbiome has a substantial effect on
the way our skin feels on the way that
our skin protects against potentially
pathogenic microbes and also how our
skin microbiome can cause things like
rashes and all kinds of other kind of
conditions that might be very unpleasant
so when we think of of you know how this
microbial
um ecosystem and an understanding of
this my into my microbial ecosystem on
our body
um can really change how we will address
these kinds of innovations that are
actually today available on you know
places like Amazon you can go and you
can find a lot of silver infused Fabric
and different kind of clothing but does
it affect the skin microbiome or does it
not right there's a lot of questions
about that and so we will have an
opportunity to address some of those
questions and kind of think about well
what is the alternative or how can or
for who maybe right um this kind of uh
product Innovation can be useful another
example that I really like is that you
know you probably have heard if you're
in the western part of the world
about many different uh metagenomic
based or microbiome based
um kind of tests that can help you pick
a right diet that can help you buy Pro
and prebiotics that are best for you and
things like that but you know as you
have more and more of these kinds of
tests and and they say that well we do
meta transcript on link or we do manage
genomic or we do just amplicon
sequencing this is an opportunity to
start thinking about well where is the
opportunity for one of these companies
to do things differently innovate and
capture the market because they're all
struggling to grow Beyond a certain
number of users and so those business
problems are related to also you know
how the public perceives the actual
benefits of microbiome sequencing or
understanding your microbiome or um you
know how to maybe link it to specific
phenotypes if there is a direct link so
those are some of the questions that we
can really focus on and I think the
important part here as we think about
solving these challenges is being able
to connect to experts that can guide us
provide us with Clarity and help us
eliminate kind of questions that are
already explored and will not lead to
anything specific
and the ultimate goal as I mentioned is
to actually build
um something and
you know the final product that you will
have is something that you will be able
to take with you for a much longer time
that will continue to be relevant Beyond
you know a a certificate that you can
simply add to your resume and I think
it's really an opportunity to develop
something that you have validation you
have feedback from experts that are in
the industry that have tried to innovate
in this space that do research in the
space right and really know how to
provide something that is very valuable
and that is something that you can
directly take and continue working on it
even you know potentially raise money
for it because there's a lot of
investment in the space you can continue
doing research um on that topic and you
can also continue to build out products
based on your understanding of what
challenges exist with the data